[Music]  someone started the party without us  let's move  we've got company  keep your eyes peeled  i see that [ __ ]  nazis hope they're all still burning in  hell  turn around show us those hands don't do  anything stupid i heard you a mile off  no offense if i'd meant you any harm  you'd already be dead how about we start  with who the [ __ ] are you and what the  [ __ ] are you doing here  relax gents  we're on the same side  i'm captain butcher of the soe  well  retired captain butcher these days  i was in charge of the soe during the  war  everett of vanguard  i created vanguard and all the others  too  it was a simpler time then  [Music]  but the work is never done  our victory wasn't earned till we  snuffed out every last spark  after berlin  we hunted down the rats that scurried  into hiding all over the world  and it started  in the pacific  [Music]  [Music]  you